hey can I ask you how did you get the
name of mr. K well I like to redefine
normal things and celebrate weirdness
yes it's totally something you do 100%
and I think that we all can embody
whatever we want to we can create our
own identity need your own label I love
that here's the deal mr. K came in and
totally renovated our entire office
space that we've had for over a year and
have done nothing of note to and now
it's the most beautiful space I've ever
been in in my entire life and you can
watch the entire transformation overall
mr. Kay's channel is fun and wild and we
painted your buttons and all of those
things happen please go watch that video
but you in but but I'm all over your arm
vent I know I mean this is appropriate
for Anna's space you make DIY really
simple it seems like ya make very
beautiful products that make me feel
like I could possibly make them all
which you can I may you make DIY I'm
very approachable I really loved your
almost oh thank you and that night I was
also drinking which brings us to this
DIY are we happy today I just wanted her
to help me with some sort of DIY that I
could present to you guys and she said
what sort of supplies do you have on
hand and I said empty liquor bottles can
we do anything with those no judgement
and you have two different DIY ideas for
us today yes first project is it's
basically a tiki lantern using lamp oil
so it's like a tiki torch thank you so
that's like a simple really cute project
and then in the spirit of Grace's just
you know fly by the seat of our pants
DIY style we're gonna do something I've
never even done before it's exciting
and that is cut-glass yep sounds really
dangerous yeah we're going to cut our
teeth on cutting glass today and we're
making succulent planters yeah so taking
a liquor bottle slicing it with a cutter
yes I got it on Amazon I watched a video
you've made these before these lanterns
I made a variation I've never used
liquor bottles before though Oh cute
okay yeah the supplies that we would
need for this liquor bottle cotton
cording this is basically like clothing
line skulky you were all familiar all us
crafters with the good ol sculpey clay
but what about us not familiar predators
what is scope bees but no like a
plasticy finish and you can make
whatever you want out of it and then you
bake it and that's how you harden it we
don't have to bake it because the candle
claim is gonna cure it for us cool and
then this is lamp oil whoo where do I
get something like this the hardware
store easily very cool and this is a
very it feels very like medieval times
Game of Thrones oh yes very very much so
all right so the first thing you would
do if you didn't like your label is to
remove your label which you could do by
just soaking it in some hot water dish
soap also Googe on I love zzy my mom
always swore by Bhutan growing up and I
never understood it I thought it was
like a dumb name for nothing and nothing
looked almost like Bhutan is a beautiful
product that and Magic Eraser yeah now
how do we find the end of it you don't
think you know I do so much with these
nails and actually what's super creepy
is either my natural nails are they have
gold scrape me underneath these two from
yesterday's project when I was painting
a promise or spoilers yep go figure out
what that actually references you want
sleep access to kind of coil up into the
bottom okay of your lamp because you
want to be able to as it burns down and
you put it out you can pull up let's see
how it looks so shall we fashion it
already very artistic Oh No okay so
basically with this company we're just
trying to create like a little like some
variation offer exactly it's a stopper
with a hole in it basically okay so am I
just kind of wrapping this around this
or am I trying to flatten this you wrap
it around the wick yeah but you want it
enough of a hole though so you can pull
it through
oh great does that make sense is that
Wow so that I made my shape I'm taking
enough for a second how much liquid do I
pour it uh you can I would say maybe go
up to like qirush okay to make sure that
we'll be able to light it uh-huh
let it and dunk the tip of it into I
mean just so that we can have like of
successful flames in relationships and
DIY you want a successful flame oh yeah
girl yeah bad II don't know you're more
than rated Los Angeles I just saw your
actual Los Angeles come out oh okay
these look super cute and I like that
they're all very different so then what
happens so now we just lay them that's
it do it later okay and now on to DIY
number two which is a it's going to be a
planter using an old wine bottle so
succulents super in we love succulents
yeah they need to take care of super
easy I can very very much advocate for
succulents cuz I kill many things in my
life relationships plants all of it and
these don't take much maintenance at all
okay so for this DIY we need obviously
succulents some sort of empty liquor
bottle from what I can tell from this
cutter a round bottle is pretty key so
it doesn't have to be wine it could be
liquor but round cool got some potting
soil I also have some decorative moss
and or some little rocks because I
always think that kind of finishes off
yeah a planter if you cover up the soil
if you see any soil around the succulent
with some rocks or mom
cute optional but cute this is a glass
cutter this is a glass cutter it comes
with this little allen wrench it also
comes with sandpaper okay because what
you want to do is lay the bottle down
after you take the label off score it
which it basically creates like an
indent doesn't totally cut it yet and
then we're gonna pour boiling water
which it sounds like it's ready yeah
heating over there water party happening
behind us so you need some boiling water
on him mm-hmm
because when you change the temperature
that weakens the Spore that much more
and it will hopefully great cool trigger
warning if any of you don't like
scratching of glass so yeah actually
yeah there might be some of that
happening or any of you ASMR fans that
really get off on that doesn't get rowdy
friends here we go here we go
a clean bottle you worked very very hard
and I appreciate your hook natural-born
nail tools yeah I was doing that okay so
now we're gonna cut this bottle longer I
am - so Briana
we're gonna score it okay I feel it
you'll be good at this because you're
you have that and I mean forwards
backwards does it matter to pick your
yeah okay pick my poor zone women but I
would stick in one direction clearly
already picked my choice and I just I
had this bottles empty
oh yeah you're doing it it's going yeah
this is dangerous okay so now we're
gonna bring it over to the sink and pour
the boiling water on it and Billy I'm
treating it like it's an exfoliant
device and you're yeah good you're
pouring it on to the score of mine okay
maybe let's stop a little cold water
oh yeah lights up yeah something's
happening I think maybe oh my gosh now
boil we're shocking it pretty and that
green glass is really nice really pretty
it's noise is gonna be fun yeah I think
lit up with the water when you put the
cool
running my finger along it and coming up
not bloody yes soil so I this little
little guys so cute so cute oh my god is
this tiniest mason jar with the handle
you've ever seen happening cute kinda
like stupid things
oh wait and as it ear nose is my dog's
name on it I have no idea where that
came from or how they got here I had to
put that in there to make herself feel
like a normal-size women oh my god I
love that it's really cute oh my god I'm
so proud of us you watched authentic
success just happened right before your
eyes
heel shot Oh beautiful
aren't they gorgeous and guys if I
haven't stress this enough please go
over to mr. Kate's channel subscribe and
watch the video of our office
transformation because it really is
truly it was like an ugly duckling like
teenager the mom if I'm not a woman well
I wish you guys all the love and luck in
the space and hopefully I can't wait
until here's video stuff like this under
this video a thumbs up if you like these
kind of DIY ideas and follow a mr. kid
on all social media what are you across
the board I'm a mister Kate calm spelled
out do TC om
I'm Sarah and all the links will be in
the description box below I'll see you
guys you know whatever
I don't know
I'll just do all of them my new ha oh my
god
where's Clarence
okay
yeah